what's the worst heckler you've had to
deal with at a show and how did you
handle them uh i had a woman throw a
wine glass at me whoa come on i was in
paso robles
kicked out of course yeah i'm doing all
these jokes about playing wolverine at
universal studios and uh that was my
life at the time so i just had 20
minutes on theme park [ __ ] and uh
and i'm looking down in between jokes
and she had said something earlier that
was a little uh off color and and just
annoying and drunk and obnoxious and i
said she at one point she goes usually
this cam gave me a kiss and i was like
should i let her give me a kiss and
everyone's like yeah so i went over
there and she like licked the side of my
face and then i made some you know dumb
joke about being like oh man i know you
could get hpv and herpes and [ __ ]
blah blah and one you know lick how many
licks does it take to get to the top of
cougar mountain or something i said and
uh and then she and i walk back to the
middle stage and i'm looking down
thinking the next joke and laughs dying
down and i'm just like i just see my
peripheral vision just this
and then i just see that like from this
side and
so quickly that i
didn't even have time to process it i
didn't have time to like you know and it
was just i just went like that
did you the base of the wine glass hits
my palm and it's just sweaty enough and
hot whatever to wear like part of the
glass like
hit and stuck almost in the webbing of
my hand to where all i had to do was
just wrap around the base of the glass
kid you not i'll call brett riley right
now he's confirmed it for me before on a
podcast where i catch it out of midair
and then i slowly turn to my hand and i
go
and everybody goes nuts and i walked
over and i set it down on her table and
i said i told you i'm wolverine [ __ ]
don't [ __ ] with me and people went nuts
and then they kicked her out and then i
got smoked out by this couple in the
back of their
uh [ __ ] uh subaru that had two doors
and they got into a big fight and i just
stayed in the back and i tried to like
slip out behind them because i got into
a big fight and i was like can you guys
let me out like this is getting pretty
heated and i'm very high and i don't
want to be back here and so like i
pushed the girl's seat up and like
slithered out
and then uh
and then went back and then the woman
was outside the hotel where we were
staying and she like like was so drunk
and was yelling at me and was just like
you embarrassed me in front of my
friends and i was like you threw a wine
glass at me
and i caught it
and then they kicked you out
and uh
and then i uh
fell asleep in the shower fully clothed
a couple of times
and then i threw a
marie calendar's chicken pot pie at the
window and broke it
jesus christ what a night
yeah
you